موسكو بتحركاته واوروبا تكثف
عقوباته على الروس امام جديد على
تخصيب اليورانيوم في منشأة فوردو
الى ستين بالمئة. الناتو يستفز
بريطانية تسعى لسرقة النفط
اليمني. بايدن يدعو تسعة واربعين
اليمنية مهددين بمواصلة استهداف
اي سفن نفطية اوروبية او
يقر بتراجع استخدام اللغة
الفرنسية في الدول المغاربية.
مجموعة السبع تنتقد اطلاق كوريا
الشمالية صاروخا باليستيا عابرا
للقارات ودعت الى عقوبات رادعة
بحق بيونج يانج. الحوثيون يعلي
وثلاثة وعشرين والتي تجاوزت
ثمانية وتسعين مليار دولار
بالحل للعراق بابعاد ما اسموه
بالجماعات الكردية عن الحدود
الرافدين اين هيبة العراق يا
هؤلاء? الاحداث والتطورات.
العمق العراقي. بينما قالت
الخارجية الايرانية ان تحركاتها
محادثات رفيعة المستوى مع
المسؤولين بشأن الصين. ليذهب
العراق وسوريا تحت النار. سوريا
والعراق مأساة السيادة العربية
وزير الدفاع الامريكي بنظيره
الصيني ويفينج لاجراء مباحثات
الخارجية للاتحاد جوزي بوريل انه
سيزور واشنطن قريبا لاجراء
رئيس افريقيا لحضور قمة الولايات
المتحدة وافريقيا في واشنطن. فما
عن رفضهم لادانتهم من قبل الامم
المتحدة بعد استهداف ميناء الضبة
في سباق مع الصواريخ الروسية
لينفذ بارواحهم. لعبة صينية
والاشتباكات في اوكرانيا. تعرضت
شبه جزيرة القرم الخاضعة للسيطرة
مصادقة الغرفة السفلى للبرلمان
الجزائري على موازنة الفين
ملفتة فابناء تيبون لا يلعبون.
الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون
عسكرية تركية قرب باب السلام.
اما العراق فرفضت حكومته الجديدة
الدول. بينما قال اردوجان ان
بلاده مستعدة للتدخل في المناطق
الذي يخطط له هذا العجوز بعد
التسريب. طهران تعترف وتقر برفع
الروسية لضربات بطائرات مسيرة
لتعلن القوات الروسية عن حالة
التأهب القصوى. فيما اعلنت وزارة
الدفاع الروسية مقتل مئة وعشرين
يصمت الروس على خطوة كهذه ومن
حرب العقوبات الى المعارك
لمنعهم من تعزيز نفوذهم. في هذا
البلد يجتمع الاعداء ويجعل من
شمال العراق تهدف لحماية حدودها
وامن موظفيها. لكن ايران تأتي
فما عادت السماء سماءهم ولا
الارض ارضهم وحتى الانهار لم تعد
الاوروبية الخيارات القانونية
لمصادرة الاصول الروسية الحكومية
موازنة في تاريخ البلاد منذ
الاستقلال. الجزائر يتطور بسرعة
الحسابات لكن هل ياتي الرفض
لوحده بالنتائج يا ابناء
وبشكل قاطع تحول الهجمات
الايرانية والتركية على اقليم
تروي ظماهم حيث تحولت سماء سوريا
لمعركة مصالح بين تركيا واسرائيل
الالماني وذلك استعدادا لمواجهة
مباشرة مع روسيا. ولكن وبالعودة
وذلك ما ينذر بمواجهة عسكرية
حتمية اكانت قريبة او بعيدة.
الغربي وبالتحديد مجلة الديرش
بيجل حيث كشفت عن خطة سرية
لتدريبات عسكرية دفاعية
وعملياتية واسعة وضعها الجيش
اجزاء مختلفة منه وهو ما يرفع
درجة التوتر بين بكين وواشنطن
واعتبرته خرقا للسيادة ورفضت ان
تتحول البلاد الى ساحة لتصفية
الغرب هكذا هنا الجيش التابع
للنظام السوري يقصف محيط قاعدة
اراضي غيرهم ساحة لحربهم. فيا له
من اجحاف بحق سوريا والعراق.
ويمكنها الوصول الى مسافات بعيدة
بحسب تليجراف البريطانية لتنضم
طلبت تركيا بعدم تنفيذ اي عملية
عسكرية في سوريا فلماذا يتساهل
يدعون انقرة الى ضبط النفس. فيما
دعا المبعوث الروسي انقرة الى
استخدام القوة المفرطة في سوريا
لتصرح الخارجية الامريكية انها
حق شرعي لحماية امن مواطنيه
ودولته. والكرملين والبنتاجون
التي تقصف منها المدن التركية
الحدودية وان كل هذا التدخل هو
اقليمي بين عدة دول ابرزها
امريكا والصين حول السيادة على
دفاعية وللحد من مخاطر التوترات
بين البلدين والسيطرة عليها
خبيثة. الترهيب والترغيب هي لغة
الصين المفضلة لكسب حليف جديد
النفطية وقد تخفض انتاج الخام
ايضا ولتبحث لكم عن مورد اخر او
هكذا يستثمر اصحاب العيون الضيقة
عقولهم ليقولها الاتحاد الاوروبي
في حضرموت. واصفين ذلك انها
وقاحة وتشجع على نهب الثروات
والخاصة والتي تقدر بخمسمائة
مليار دول ليتم تحويلها الى
للارهاب، وسابقا ندد بوتين
باتخاذ هذه الخطوة محذرا من رد
الى بريطانيا. هنا تكمن المفاجأة
حيث ذكرت صحيفة صنداي تايمز ان
البريطانية وقف واردات النفط من
روسيا في اطار العقوبات الغربية.
المانيا الى قافلة الدعم
لاوكرانيا مجددا وباعلان من
المستشار الالماني اولف شولز
بتجديد عهده والتزام بلاده بدعم
وروسيا فبغاراتها وبنوك اهدافها
تستهدف هذه الدول الثلاث خصومها
والمعلومات اللوجستية الى
العقوبات? حيث تدرس المفوضية
بينما صرحت الدفاع الصيني ان على
الولايات المتحدة احترام المصالح
وذلك جراء قصف روسي عنيف. جميع
السكان يتوجهون الى الملاجئ وذلك
المشتركة. فيا له من حل سحري
يستمر انتهاك السيادة من قبل هذه
فهنا القصف التركي يجبر سكان
ستين قرية كردية على النزوح الى
لتحديد ستين دولارا كسقف لسعر
البرميل من النفط الروسي فهل
لن تواصل شراء النفط الروسي على
الرغم من ادعاء السلطات
الاساسية للصين. وان تايوان خط
احمر وتعود قضية الصين ولا يحق
وبعد هذا الاستعراض اعلنت
بريطانيا عن تزويد اوكرانيا
الحرب في اوكرانيا بينما يسعى
الاتحاد الاوروبي ومجموعة السبع
لاي قوة خارجية التدخل حيث يعتبر
بحر الصين الجنوبي ساحة نزاع
الخارجي. فهل من مغيث? والجزائر
تقر اكبر موازنة في تاريخها.
الناتو يامستولتنبرج لن نسمح
لروسيا ان تنتصر في الحرب. واكد
باتريوت لتسقط هنا وثيقة
استخباراتية سهوا بايدي الاعلام
اذهبوا لجمع الحطب يقولها الروس
ليعلنها الامين العام لحلف
البيت الابيض ان واشنطن ستواصل
دعم فرض حد اقصى لسعر النفط على
حيث عرضت تأمين المجال الجوي لها
وتزويدها بنظام الدفاع الجوي
ضد روسيا وتعلن حمايتها لبولندا.
الاوروبيون يقفون في صف وواشنطن
الذي يجري سنطلق صواريخنا وحيثما
سقطت فلتسقط. نعم عن المجنون
والحوثيون يرفضون قرار الامم
وبيض يجتمع بتسع واربعين دولة من
لقد حان وقت العقاب يا بوتين.
هكذا قالتها اوروبا فمن سيعاقب
سلاحا متطورا قد يحسم المعارك في
اوكرانيا والمانيا تستعد للحرب
هي الهدف. بينما تجري الولايات
المتحدة جلسات تفاوض مع بكين فما
كييف عسكريا. المانيا لم تكتف
بذلك لتتقدم بعرض مغر لبولندا
باحدث نسخة من صواريخ بريمستون
المتطورة والدقيقة والتي بالليزر
تكاليف لاعادة اعمار اوكرانيا
وذلك بحسب مجلة بوليتيكو. فهل
فهل يلعب الانجليز على الحبلين
ومن المكاتب الاستخباراتية
كارثي اذا حدثت، وها هي قد حدثت
اليوم يا بوتين. فما هو ردك؟
الامريكان نحو الصين مباشرة
ويبدأون المفاوضات حيث التقى
نرفض وبشدة التشدد الامريكي ضد
الصين. ويصرح منسق السياسة
الى خارج الحدود الاوكرانية.
وهنا يزيد الاوروبي الطين بلة،
كييف وخرسون وعدة مدن اوكرانية
ليسمع بعدها دوي انفجارات ضخمة
جنديا اوكرانيا باتجاه مدينة
دونيسك. وصافرة الانذار تصرخ في
عندما صرح نائب رئيس الوزراء
الروسي الكسندر نوفاك ان روسيا
الارض الاوكرانية. وسيادة سوريا
والعراق في مهب الريح.
يقبل الروس بذلك? الرد الروسي
كان قد استبق القرار الغربي
وذلك بتصويته بالموافقة على
اعلان روسيا كدولة راعية
ستولتنبرج ان الحلف ضعف عدد
قواته شرقا لمنع امتداد الصراع
الاشتباكات في الحرب الاوكرانية
لتندلع حرب من نوع اخر حيث اكد
بنسبة مخيفة. روسيا تشعل حربا
جديدة. دخل الشتاء وقلت
لن تشحن النفط او اي منتج منه
دول تفرض سقفا لاسعار صادراتها
امل ان يحد ذلك من قدرة الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين على تمويل
افريقيا من اجل هذا الهدف وايران
تعلن زيادة تخصيب اليورانيوم
نتحدث. والعراق وسوريا بلدان
يشكوان لبعضهما وطأة القصف
حربا من نوع اخر ضد روسيا وموسكو
ترد على الفور. بريطانيا تقدم
من? والولايات المتحدة ومجموعة
السبع والاتحاد الاوروبي يعلنون